okay so we got legend Cora here the
civil wars part 1 and oh it's nice
tights we have this like the day it the
day after it comes out I mean we're
literally doing this right after it
aired so that's uh that's pretty cool
not right after there died DVR
revolution okay it was one hour later
oh the funny characters are still funny
that that wasn't that uncle guy what a
riot yeah okay he's I just think it was
funny though but Bumi's still funny the
artist formerly known as Howard Hughes
is still funny um well go ahead what is
his name I
they said it once and I was like that
thing catch it so just varus yeah his I
keep forgetting they all kill yo down
there don't shy but yeah and I guess
here it's okay so there's a see like
gore walks into where the uncle is
sitting and literally it's like a
totally black room he's sitting on his
throat and there's a shadow over him
it's like how can you I guess I just
gotta be that well my parrot is yeah the
second they show that see me sitting
there and you just go I'm still not
being the villain so I mean they're
dragging their feet on this though like
it's piano still he's still not out it
is pure villain yet but uh but I will
say like there's still stuff may not be
a pure villain we don't know so there's
stuff that he still says to her that
seems like okay like you can see why
she's still drawn over to his side not
just the confidence he has in her but
the way he talks it's like it seems very
sort of yeah well this logically makes
sense and you can see her starting to
question it way of speaking yes well did
anyone bring balance to spare yeah it
would be nice we had a little bit more
emotion actually is very you go Harry
radium Neeson in
yeah I'm not usually a fan but you know
whatever um and we got a little bit more
of her sort of rebellious leg
oh I'm just gonna rush into something a
lot but I will met at the end of this
one because she thinks that the father
is he's kidnapping the brother and turns
out he's not and when she comes in and
sees the mother and father Hubley
oops no but that worked and you know
yeah if she realized she made a mistake
well no no but it the fact that she not
even that she made a mistake that she
thought he would actually do it and you
cuz you could feel that she's
calculating in her head oh my god what's
this gonna me like he she's even like if
you leave now I won't tell anybody but
you had to put him back and she's just
already counting your head oh my god no
I gotta go to jail this is gonna be the
end and suddenly the stuff he did before
it doesn't seem as bad I like that scene
too because she was trying to give what
she thought was her dad every single
sort of out so even if her dad was
quote-unquote betraying the Northern
Water Tribe or whatever she was still
mad trying to just grab him and just say
yeah screw Bisson yeah she was trying to
give him every chance to not do it yeah
so I like to see where she comes back
and she sees you know the parents there
does again the traditional sorry scene
that we seen a lot from her but there I
felt it really worked because she didn't
have to tell him why Sarah Lee I mean I
think she sort of does but it's just
that she realized oh you didn't do this
and I'm sorry I ever thought that you
would do this it's not even something
that he did is saying that she thought
he would have done and and I like that I
I thought that was what he was arrested
so oh yeah then it's like what the hell
so um so yeah that's that's great fun oh
I'm really fascinated with the way
tenzin blow my dad is sir there is a ton
of childhood regret I'm like this is
like a dr. Phillips and what's so
interesting find that more interesting
than the other
no I do when I was like what when I
turned the camera here I'm like okay
what happened it's like I was thinking
yeah mostly of like tension as brother
and sister I was like wow that was me
it's like sitting in at a party and a
couple of siblings or something go ahead
and then all of a sudden it's like wow
this was revealing I'm just gonna look
over here while they're talking yeah you
know yeah and it's it's interesting cuz
you wouldn't because Aang is you know
the avatar and the old monk / dad always
took you to ride the elephant-koi what's
up with that well mom always took you to
ride the elephant penguins cuz it was
fun I just wonder one elephant penguin
looks like that you know what creators
make that yeah yeah let's see that if
not by the grace of the show just
somebody below draw that it put a link
to it know that whole section of the
story yeah I found the most interesting
like how like okay so this wasn't
exactly a happy childhood and now we're
all angry bitter at all well what's so
interesting that it's not
hey these three just couldn't get along
or something like that it was
specifically Aang liked him the most and
would take him on vacations without the
other two which is like you wouldn't
think that of Eng which is why it's so
fascinating I'm almost wondering if
that's something where it's like hey was
this something he really kind of did or
was or was this something where it's
like well they severing it or seeing it
ends and re only airbenders so there was
probably that connection and he wants to
pass on the whole airbending thing okay
I think of is that maybe he was like
training him harder to and that's why
such a stick-in-the-mud yeah but you
know what knowing Aang it probably
started off as like yes this is gonna be
some spiritual mission oh elephant koi
well I think we're assume a me we solve
in some of your flashbacks like when he
grows up he's he's more mature I mean oh
he's more mature but I could totally see
like that happening like oh yeah and
this is where we're gonna meditate and
then oh holy crap elephant koi let's get
the only way I can see working it right
now is that he would reveal that
actually an like worked it really hard
to be there better to be the responsible
one that's why he's the stick in the mud
but he did give him rewards too that's
the only thing I can
it's like I just coming with fire I I'm
pretty sure that each is the product of
some quirk in the parenting well that
what they mentioned that baby is the
oldest one but he acts like the youngest
um you know who Tenzin was going on
about how like yeah were you always
running around it was about time you
settle down after Dad died and did
something for Mom and I'm just like holy
Cripe enjoyably awkward cuz I dip
anything what tense it is just always
long you know what kills me most of all
is I love the the way the end credits
run because it's almost like the end
credits just showed up and were just
like you know whatever just we're just
gonna let them go and we're just gonna
run the end credits cuz this may be a
while you know what to see what happens
yeah what we watch we're just gonna cut
away yeah I mean we watch this you know
and I'm Nick on a nick HD and for
whatever reason the credits didn't run
like right before the end it ran when
the three of them are arguing and then
stopped us are waiting for like you know
it to fade to black cos I guess they're
doing they did that last time too though
I guess they're doing it so it didn't
interrupt another like oh it's not
writing but it's so funny just to have
this long argument what you like your
best religion and all this of the
credits start running just like just cut
away never mind that's we're just doing
the cry that's okay we're gone by so uh
it was almost like the Oscars where they
have the music to play off when you're
going too long it's like alright we're
gonna run the credits maybe that'll shut
em up so um yeah I mean I think that was
by far the bed and not too much of a
connection to the last two episodes
early we have the the army coming in
they're addressing that but I honestly I
know it's a part one so compared to last
episode I thought this one was slightly
more fillory like i felt like it was
very it was much slower pace wait it was
slower paced but I felt it was okay I
think because the last do we did see so
much of the spirits and stuff like that
um it looks like it's gonna lead to
something big in the next one with like
the trial and everything so oh it's not
okay with me it wasn't totally like hey
you could just cut that episode it seems
like no this is definitely here
and got some good stuff going on but
yeah again also we don't know how many
episodes they have this season so I mean
we have no idea this is like twelve or
twenty whatever so be interesting to see
how this goes but uh um well did you
notice there was one thing they did
mention was it which they did not really
bring up in the first episode she says
at some point because somebody brought
this up and I'm like me I had thought of
it last time but I forgot to mention it
which is we were complaining that her
reaction to Tenzin was cruel the way he
just you know it's like it's been an
honor serving you and she's like yeah
you know so you know I've heard
mentioned and I I do agree like well she
could be angry because Tenzin's in on
this lie you know about her father like
her father's Gucci she shouldn't know
them though about the lie she found
about the father later after that oh did
she
yeah so that is defo right there yeah
well there you go there but that is
mentioned now in this episode there's
like Tenzin you know my dad Tenzin they
were both holding me back so maybe
that's why I don't think they're
referring to the lie I think they're
talking more about just in general like
hey let me be the avatar we would travel
more training more training they return
on alter all her life is what it is but
I mean he had to I mean Tenzin had to
have known his father's past when you
think I guess I don't know would they
cuz I'm Tenzin oh I don't
know I don't see the essential like you
would have to know I mean I'm just
wondering if they're gonna do something
with that commanded not sure but there
is one in there is also one other really
interesting thing which is have you
noticed that this is the exact opposite
of Aang story arc like an exact 180
degrees what was Aang's story arc I
never wanted to be the avatar I wanted
to be a normal yet here was Korra story
I returned
I never wanted to be a normal kid I want
to be the effort yeah I like how I was
at the you know the actual fighting and
stuff and going to the Avatar State
comes very natural to her but the
philosophies you know it is harder to
come across something I personally like
it yeah the only thing I'm still a
little afraid of you see a little bit of
this again is that it may be a touch of
the regression in Cora and what I found
out with it with Aang's character is
that I found if Cora was doing this and
we did not have last airbender I hate
making that comparison but if if this
was going on I probably be more
forgiving of it by things the fact that
Aang was brought in and he was still kid
and they acknowledged that but he still
acted for the most part very adult when
these troubling times were coming and he
wasn't a white or he wasn't a complainer
so when you have that first and then you
have this character it's a tough act to
follow so I think it's okay then sheet
like I said that she's Robin she wants
to rush in and she makes a lot of
mistakes but I think sort of that
constant Prive constant well I'm the
avatar I'm the avatar like you said just
sort of that in the first season it's
okay but it's here when she's just not
learning and how many times is she gonna
apologize and stuff it's like so for
here wasn't too bad but I'm hoping it's
not like the formula or the pattern I
had oh I wouldn't have as much of a
problem with it if we hadn't already
gone through a first season exactly you
know and oh that's yeah what bothers me
is we we did this in the first season in
the end this may be because they got
stuck because they had no idea how many
more seasons were going to come after
this so they're just like okay let's
throw everything we can into this season
and now they're there so I could the
first one in you her progression though
I mean they could I had to turn the
problem is the first one ended with this
giant spiritual moment of her hitting
the ultimate low and then you know you
would think that would do something well
yeah that would stick in her head um but
that's the thing no they may be looking
at this like well now where do we go we
had her come home spirit or real as they
take it's over
you could take it somewhere that
wouldn't just be a repeating ground many
of them you could have if you didn't
just give her all her powers back which
again maybe I'm from the bank yet they
on where they were gonna even be on that
you know people are interesting it's not
like Oh once you hit that stage you're
not interesting anymore no fine what's
gonna make that person interesting after
you hit the lowest moment the highest
moment or whatever cuz you can keep
going um so that's my one fear is that I
don't know what do I get yeah I hope we
don't go through the whole formula
beginning to end all over again but the
idea that she's got a lot of
self-confidence and a lot of I'm the
Avatar doesn't that depth that goes back
to episode one and I damn well like I
have no issue on that is a bad girl that
was her first line no no no it was like
freaking avatar and actually that's what
made me think Oh like I'm really gonna
like this and I like that was different
it's the fact that like like we were
saying just just so that repetition that
formula and and so that not you know
what is it's that not caring for others
it's that constantly thinking of herself
at the end of episode she's gonna
realize I should have thought of myself
it's that constant formula over and over
and is some variation would be nice I
mean I think the thing for me is I don't
my major issue with it I mean this could
totally change over the course of the
season we're only in like episode 2 or
yeah 3 I guess over we're gonna talk
about the first one but I don't feel
like there's been any progression
whatsoever we're just kind of back to
square one yeah you know which is not
terrible if they want to do it all over
again they can but you know I understand
she doesn't have to be perfect at the
same time I'm like I don't feel like
I've seen any change now from season one
she seems to me like the exact same
character yeah like whatever and all the
character whatever call thing to my
senses
and even even what's his name uh ly
Afghani uh Bolin like even he in a sense
is kind of the people moving on to other
girlfriends is yeah well mom ACOs can't
the same but
Mako's can the same Bamako is putting in
an effort yeah he's trying to do this
whole relationship thing I okay yeah
this is actually my problem is I think
it's not putting it together in my head
it's good take a while but it she just
isn't that interesting of a character
this time around compared to as we saw
it the first season yeah its Tenzin amok
ou are doing all of these things so far
this season I'm just not really that
interested nothing has happened with her
character that has been that interesting
what what revelations have there been
what is changed you know so far it's why
I'm upset at my dad I'm like okay that's
fair I get that but there there's
nothing else really to cling to it's
kind of like you're just exactly the
same as you were in season one yeah we
can oh she's gonna be duped and that
Tarlac to was gonna keep using her as a
puppet until she wakes up won't just be
wrong though I would love it if all of a
sudden it's like this some huge trick
would be surreal I would be thrilled if
that was the case but I I can't turns
out he was good along her father was
evil one egg lavish that would be
awesome
what are you tweets I don't see them
going that route though um that would
totally like pull the rug out from under
us but I don't see them going that round
um but ya know I serve agree it's just
she's not that interesting right now and
I think you could make her intra it'd be
difficult but I think you could make her
interesting after going through all that
stuff and still evolving the character
um so hopefully they will hopefully
they'll do something fun with Lu so
we're only on Episode three but I just
so far in the three episodes I just feel
like there's nothing going on yeah like
usually there's all this really cool
stuff
oh yeah and avatar Korra goes hit
something let's just like it's like
everybody has all this interesting
character development or some sort of
progression or something going on and
with her I just feel like it's chess
piece storytelling like yeah she goes
here she does this she activates this
she
it's very video game at just you're
throwing complain it'll switch sorta
light comes on and then maybe there's an
apology so I don't feel like I know her
character any better after these three
epochs yeah that's a great way of
putting we're fine so much about tensing
and these other people and where I feel
like I'm out to go like a whatever mock
Oh is you know trying his best you know
I'm like okay that's something we'd ever
seen ah yeah so not very good point so
okay that's it and we'll see you guys
for I guess episode 4 civil wars bye -
see you there